[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back to
What's New in Android.
SPEAKER 2: First, we'll
start with distribution. you.
You saw in the keynote, we
introduced the dynamic app
bundles.
Towards the end, it was pretty
clear it's pretty easy for you.
All you have to do is
click a different menu
when you build your application.
And we're going to
save you some space.
It's going to be faster
and easier for your users
to download your app.
SPEAKER 1: Let's talk
about Android Jetpack.
This is a set of
components as well as
guidance on how to build
better Android applications.
All of you are familiar
with most of what
is in Android Jetpack already.
What we're doing is
adding to it over time
with stuff that's going
to make it even better.
And we're also
improving it over time.
One of the major steps
that we're taking
is what I like to think of
as a refactor, because it's
a refactor.
And we're doing a whole
lot of tedious renaming.
And we're also providing
tools to make it easier
for you to do the similar
refactoring that you're
going to need to do
in your application,
as well as in Android Studio.
Everything is being renamed
to something more appropriate
called Androidx.
Jetpack architecture is
about architecture components
that were announced
last year at I/O,
and then iterated with
feedback from the community,
and finally went
1.0 in the fall.
Work Manager is
currently in preview.
There's going to
be a talk about it.
Also navigation-- it
turns out that up versus
back is a hard problem
for applications to solve.
We are making that
much easier, and we're
integrating with the tool
to make it even easier yet.
SPEAKER 2: Kotlin--
it's the [INAUDIBLE]
thing we announced last year.
So we're busy.
We want to make it better
for all the Kotlin developers
out there.
I'm sure there's a
lot of you here today.
So some of the things
we've been doing.
The ART team has been really
busy with D8, R8, and ART
itself.
They've been looking at
the bytecode generated
by the Kotlin compiler.
They've analyzed some of
the bytecode patterns that
were different from the
ones generated by the Java
programming language compiler.
And they've been optimizing
for those patterns.
We've also been adding a lot
of nullability annotations
to our Java APIs, both
in the core libraries--
so libcore-- and our
support libraries
to make it easier for
you to use the platform
APIs when you're in Kotlin.
And finally, we
launched on GitHub
a new library
called android-ktx.
It's a set of Kotlin extensions
for existing platform APIs.
And the goal here is to
try to take advantage
of some of the Kotlin
language features
to make existing
APIs easier to use.
They're already easier to
use just by using Kotlin,
but with the extension,
they get even better.
SPEAKER 3: So Slices is our
new approach to remote content
that you can actually use to
project UI into your own app
or into other apps
that support it.
It's very structured.
This is not sort of here's a
canvas or an absolute layout.
Go nuts with it.
We give you a structure to fill
out and a whole bunch of very
flexible templates in which to
populate that data with some
display hints, so that the
receiving end of the Slice--
the Slice host--
kind of knows what
to do with it.
These are interactive.
These are updateable.
This is meant to be something
that holds rich UI-- sliders,
controls, live information,
possibly videos--
things that actually feel
like real UI as opposed
to a snapshot of something
happening in a distant process
somewhere.
Slices are addressable
by content URI,
and this is how they're
passed around the system
and how they're passed
along to app indexing
to be shown in
context-like search.
And then finally,
Slices is entirely
inside the support library.
It's entirely in Jetpack, so
it's backwards-compatible.
You can use Slices all
the way back to API 19.
Related to Slices is Actions.
You can think of these as
shortcuts with parameters.
[INAUDIBLE] likes to think
of them as visible intents.
This is essentially a
deep link into your app
with some additional payload.
It's not just a link to music.
It's linked to the particular
album or something like that.
And you saw these as
well in the keynotes,
showing up in predictive
space inside our app launching
experience--
actions you define
in an actions XML
file that goes into
your APK or app bundle.
And that too can get
registered with app indexing
so that search results
and predictive features
can show those actions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]